hello rejects Greg here with Kyle either
Minh Kyle I Lerman who you can follow on
periscope a in Twitter anyway he's a
friend of mine from acting class we act
together
I played Ben Affleck and one scene he
played jeremy renner name that movie
movie trivia show normally we're this is
a film channel we like to talk a lot
about films we do like these reaction
videos but I tend to keep it with
something that is still film based there
whether it be TV shows or actors or just
movies in general but Thanksgiving is
upon us so I thought we'd do a special
kind of covering a Thanksgiving topic
five deadly Black Friday disasters what
better way to celebrate the holidays and
horrible things that happen the day
after Thanksgiving dark five is a great
channel do you save up for Black Friday
no not anymore
I don't ever save up for Black Friday
kind of hate it I just shop on it oh
yeah i if I'm gonna do a Black Friday
deal I'm just like it's going Amazon
well if I'm gonna go is store wait to
like yeah do these crazy in there yeah I
agree online is the best gosh and the
people bring their kids to like a
midnight people shoppings people done I
hope this video covers that it's horri
people have to know the horrors of
Thanksgiving and Christmas what it
brings to us to save some money
dark five presents it's a great channel
by the way I subscribe to these guys
race to the bottom
at 5:00 a.m. on Friday November 28 2008
a mob of 2,000 crates shoppers began
pounding on the gates of a Long Island
Walmart open the [ __ ] door Walmart
chanting push the Dawes in before
ripping the barrier off its hinges and
stamping and stampeding inside like wild
animals man they're really describing
this mob yeah okay
caught in front of the ramping bore was
she would tell edge it for a temporary
Walmart worker who was crushed beneath
her feet ouch terribly [ __ ] man I always
like the horrible things it's okay okay
the genuine reaction entitled shoppers
screaming that they have been in line
all morning and Nordisk pleas for
helping trample the man to death dude
you gotta like stand up for yourself
surviving employees clamoring on top of
vending machines to escape the greedy
mobs deranged rush to save $20 Navy
that's so funny all right $20 when did
this safe place again 2008 wow this is
like 25 years ago something like this
happened I may be a little under $20
been a lot you know like many years ago
yeah people do anything you say and they
think that they're getting a really good
deal yeah I always do I don't
participate this [ __ ] anymore it's
horrible what I do when I go through a
Black Friday sale is I constantly look
out for who I'm stepping on yeah do they
look important are they someone who
deserves to live so I'm very selective
about okay
yeah I'll step on this person this
person's pregnant and maybe I shouldn't
step on them cuz then I'll just feel a
little bad about myself a lot of people
will rush in and they'll get things that
they don't even necessarily think they
want yeah oh it's cheap get it this is a
problem of America this is what happens
name only imagine now with America let's
not get into a trump debate try to
probably especially with me it's
probably for that trying to stop it's
not bringing them up on this channel
like out at least two deadly car
accidents have been blamed of the
madness of Black Friday's late night
sales
I gotta get a Black Friday text is
overstay its welcome a little bit 2012
Arvind tango has been shopping on three
hours sleep before he fell asleep at the
wheel on a California freeway
let's draw a highway patrol car oh man
oh no oh no Jenna BLAP crushing two of
his daughters riding with him because
they were rushing also fell asleep while
driving home from a midnight black
friday sale
okay
oh my god that's like final destination
whoa
every time I've fallen asleep behind the
wheel I usually have like other people
in the car me who can notice something
lucky there I start to swerve off the
side like what you're right yeah yeah
you can make it a big don't worry right
it's just so weird how like I can't
fully judge like the situation what's
going on like they want to save money
and then you know it's smart to save
money so Black Riders are a good idea
but then you can get a little too
extreme about it anytime it's gotten
this bad it's it's not worth it
yeah like the greed for more or the
desire to save okay like give me all you
always be taking it I mean straight
technically it is one of the deadliest
sins those seven the seven deadly greed
that's why Kevin Spacey chopped off
Gwyneth Paltrow's head I just ruined the
ending of seven for all of you who
haven't seen it if you didn't know I was
referencing seven I have definitely ruin
it for you
you haven't seen anybody now there's
something wrong there's something wrong
with you just see it
2008 Black Friday two men were killed in
a bloody gun battle today these are us
what's wrong people why why they have
guns at Toys R Us two teenage girls
fought inside the pack toy store the men
accompanied them pulled out guns oh gosh
fight was over a toys of the commotion
and louder and louder was punctuated by
gunshots where's the shoppers a near
ride ensue with people screaming and
pounding on police cars arriving outside
Wow
no police they died when you go to the
store bring a gun you never know who
else is gonna have a gun when you go to
the store to a toy store the toy a store
Ralph's sometimes I'm low on cat food no
and then I have to go get cat food and I
like to get the grain free for my cats
as I don't want them to get like some
type of disease or get old bastard I'll
get the grain free but sometimes there's
some like fat lady who wants grain free
cat food is only oh my god why can't she
has a gun I have a gun and I usually win
that's why I'm here doing reactions for
you guys so the kind of commentary I do
yeah kill a [ __ ] kill a [ __ ] if you
have to two guns
I'd say bring two guns
that's horrible is a [ __ ] up event
yeah that's really but they didn't show
pictures of the real people they don't
have a name so I don't yeah I'll
personally feel there did I wonder if
the kids were with them probably let's
get her to be great warriors yeah yeah
imagine just beat it it's like the last
place you'd expect like whoa people
having a gun shoot out that yeah I would
never go to Toys R Us after hearing that
story again I'm one of those people
happens one time done you've learned
don't quote it's what I heard once about
a gun battle that took place at Toys R
Us I would never go there yeah never
Granta happened once in past decades
it's been around Black Friday man more
like dark Friday yeah
heart-stopping deals people have a heart
attacks of how great
Walter Vance collapsed while shopping
for Christmas decorations in West
Virginia Target nice yt collapse yet the
unfazed crowd norm as he lay writhing on
the wow we are so insensitive to people
sometimes
so that is crazy it's Virginia though
you know I can't be mr. Lee understand
eager to snatch up targets doorbuster
deals shoppers push their carts around
Vance in the middle of his heart attack
God well he said they close at the aisle
before Vance gonna be taken to the
hospital where he ultimately died and he
potentially could have maybe made it
yeah had people not ah gotta get my deal
who cares about my soul I just noticed
that people didn't help what the reason
was other than greed yeah that's all of
us
I have four even with the last one yeah
that's just sick that's not even human
in my opinion you mean that if you saw
like a great deal that you've been
waiting for for a long time and someone
was dying on the floor
you thought it just strangely I don't
know why I think you feel like you'd
actually like stop what you're doing
yeah yeah for this person you know what
do we need call a doctor I messed up
right like I'm sick well do you that's
the thing man you can't give yourself
too much to other people especially
strangers you can't trust Rangers for
all you know he was just pulling a
little trick try to get you to like you
take you down knock you out so he didn't
get a better deal you get the last item
I could see why people in Virginia
thought it was a Kong cause Virginians
sometimes aren't the brightest people
you know I'm sure there's some good
people there perhaps just now that it's
Black Friday story says other boy what's
crazy these stories are happening the
day after Thanksgiving the day where
we're supposed to be all loving and
thing I'm grateful for those in our life
and people and our families once an
appreciate kind yeah and and then the
next day that all just goes out the
window it's midnight when that goes out
the window although if you think about
it goes from greed to gluttony then
greed because we're I wouldn't hits
midnight you know you stop eating you're
stuffing yeah fattening yourself up so
you can totally not give a [ __ ] about
other people because they're too fat and
you're trying to keep moving in the
store but you're bloated as [ __ ] five
left see how many more sins we can not
get out of here fire sale
one of the darkest events linked to
Black Friday a 2014 robbery plot of text
and isn't a terrible murder of a mall
manager Paul ward sorry
that's what you do Carter Cervantes and
Clarence Mallory staked out an American
Eagle the target employees who might
have the store's keys oh my god why
American Eagle
you
oh so worth it
greed is not good Gordon Gekko 50 grand
that's it
that'll only last you so long like yeah
to go that far in life for 50 grand like
that that'll only take you so far no it
won't take you very far at all it's
that's still considered lower-class if
you make that in a year yeah so sad how
how little the value of human life is to
some people I mean I was crazy I thought
that wasn't even like a store incident
that's like they tracked her down they
found her in her home have sex oh there
was envy though there's a lotta Envy
here
yeah whole thing derives from Envy yeah
I'm wanting to get that product so you
can look better than other people
ah well guys Black Friday is right
around the corner
I hope you guys have a great
Thanksgiving and also have a great time
shopping at your local Walmart don't
judge our us don't kill don't die and
don't kill two of the most maybe your
device maybe help people when they're
falling over they look like they're
possibly dead maybe call someone take a
moment to stop and go are you really in
pain but be hesitant because they might
just be trying to pull you down i trick
you so they can get the better you thank
you thank you cop because you can't be
too careful and bring a gun with you oh
my god
bring don't have to use it just in case
someone else has a gun new the channel
you can subscribe your day and become a
reject and that's not what I say I say
alright it rejects subscribe today and
get accepted exact opposite that's right
Kyle Yzerman I'm gonna also show Muse
that all social media if I didn't move
it all all of them are in the
description box yeah right there right
before right below the link where it
says original video link to this and
subscribe to dark five they have great
content they really know how to get you
into Thanksgiving spirit take care
Trump's America